(upbeat music)
- This is Taylor, Texas.
And it might feel like we
are in the middle of nowhere
but we're only about a half hour
outside of one of America's
biggest boom towns, Austin.
Taylor only has about 17,000 people
and the downtown has
shrunk in recent years
but that's about to change
because of a huge investment.
- Samsung has chosen
Taylor, Texas as the site
of his new state of the art
semiconductor chip fabrication plant.
- [Rob] Last fall, Samsung
the world's largest semiconductor maker
announced that would build
a $17 billion chip fabrication
plant or fab in Taylor
creating more than 2,000 jobs.
And Samsung isn't alone,
Intel, Texas Instruments
and TSMC are also returning
their chip manufacturing to the US.
These companies were lured by
new state and local subsidies
and they could soon
receive even more money
from the federal government.
- If we'd be able to say made
in Ohio, made in America,
but we used to always be
able to say 25, 30 years ago.
That's what this is about.
- [Rob] America has
long been losing ground
in the race to make chips.
That's fueling bipartisan concerns
about our reliance on those made abroad.
And that's a problem
because semiconductors
are basically the
foundation of modern life.
They're in your car,
they're in your phone,
your laptop and even your washing machine.
But thanks to the pandemic,
chips have become harder to find.
The pandemic led to a spike
in global semiconductor sales
and that led to product
delays for consumers
and highlighted a growing problem.
America isn't anywhere near
making as many chips as it needs.
I sat down with Samsung
Executive, Jon Taylor
at the company's Austin campus.
How big is that plant going to be?
- You know, we've got
1,200 acres in Taylor
so we're gonna construct 6
million square feet of buildings.
The capacity that we're
gonna bring online in Taylor
is really gonna help us
give a lot of opportunity to our customers
and also help us to contribute
to the stability of the
semiconductor supply chain problem.
- [Rob] To woo Samsung,
local and state governments offered
a slew of financial incentives.
The City of Taylor and Williamson County
offered 90% property tax
breaks for the first 10 years.
The State of Texas threw
in $27 million of its own.
In return, Samsung offered
to make donations to local schools
and guaranteed career
help for Taylor students.
But some have questioned
if subsidies should even be necessary.
- We are debating legislation
to provide some $53 billion,
billion dollars in corporate welfare
with no strings attached
to the highly profitable
micro chip industry.
- [Rob] Samsung is one of the world's
most valuable companies,
it's worth around $388 billion.
- So we're a few miles
from downtown Austin here.
Downtown Austin is full of cranes,
big tech companies coming
that aren't getting subsidies.
They're bringing jobs here
and they're not asking
for anything in return.
Why do you need subsidies
in order to build this plant in Taylor?
If it's a great business
offer opportunity,
why not just build it?
- I think the incentive
packages certainly lure
a lot of top companies here.
It makes it a competitive advantage
not only country to country,
but just within the states.
Texas and Williamson county and the city
aren't the only areas that are
offering incentive packages.
Certainly other places
that we look did the same.
Everybody would like to be able to get
these type of projects again in their area
'cause they can see the
economic development
that will happen
and that's generational development too.
This is not just short term,
it's really a long term investment.
- [Rob] Samsung recently broke ground
on the Taylor site
and the company said it's fab
would be up and running
by the end of 2024.
James Lewis is a technology
and public policy researcher
at CSIS, a DC think tank.
- Countries we have to
worry about are China.
- China, basically China.
- What happens to the American economy
or to the American consumers
ability to buy things
if China decides that they
don't want Taiwan shipping
quite as many any chips to the US?
- If China were decide
to cut off supplies from
Taiwan of semiconductors,
it would cripple the global economy.
- [Rob] In 1990, the
US and Europe produced
more than 75% of the world semiconductors.
Now, they produce less than a quarter.
Japan, South Korea, Taiwan, and China
are squeezing out the West.
If those trends hold,
by 2030 China will become the
world's largest chip maker.
Aggravating matters is the
sheer thirst for chips in the US
even though domestic
production has fallen,
demand for chips at home remain sky high.
As of 2019, nearly half
of all chips world wide
were bought by US companies.
- Are there any examples from history
of America ramping up production
of something like semiconductors
and being able to displace
some of those imports?
- You know, the idea that
we would use policy solution
to increase production is not a new one
and it's industrial policy
which used to be a
dirty word in Washington
now you can say it railroads on airplanes,
spacecraft and semiconductors themselves.
All these grew out of
government investments.
- America invented these chips
and federal research and development
led to the creation of these chips.
Taxpayer dollars.
Over 30 years ago,
America had about 40%
of global production.
But since that time something happened.
American manufacturing,
the backbone of our
economy got hollowed out.
- [Rob] In the past,
the US didn't have federal
incentives for chip making.
On the other hand,
Asian countries typically
offer cheap land to chip makers
and subsidized manufacturing equipment.
- That's one of the reasons that our share
of chip manufacturing has declined.
Everyone else subsidizes, we don't.
The Chinese in particular
have been willing to dump
tens of billions of
dollars into subsidies.
And so everyone has figured out,
this is a strategic industry,
government can play a role by
accelerating investment in it.
- [Rob] The Biden
administration in Congress
have set in motion
legislation to provide funding
to stimulate investment in the US.
In June, the Senate approved $52 billion
in direct subsidies for new
semiconductor factories.
The house has yet to take action.
- Don't think of dollars,
think of aircraft carriers.
You want a fab,
that's two or three
aircraft carriers, right?
We're talking huge investments
to build these things.
- And by comparing it
to an aircraft carrier,
you're comparing it to national defense.
You're saying this can
be as valuable for us
as another aircraft carrier.
- In fact, it's more valuable for us.
Chips are more valuable for us
than another aircraft carrier.
It's the chips industry
that is now underpinning
the whole digital economy.
- [Rob] In March, the CEOs
of major semiconductor companies
testified at a Senate hearing
about the chip shortage.
They also encourage lawmakers
to pass the Chips Act.
- In 1990, 80% of semiconductors
were built in US and Europe.
Today, 80% is in Asia
with only 12% in the US
and half of that being Intel.
Asian countries moved aggressively
to attract this industry with
strong and center policies.
Assuming we received
support from the Chips Act,
the total investment
from the site could grow
to as much as 100 billion
over the next decade.
We have also thrown our
factory doors open wide
to provide capacity for US
and global foundry companies.
We seek to rebuild the entire
supply chain on US soil.
- [Rob] One thing is for sure
the chip shortage is far from over.
Last month, Intel Chief Gelsinger
said the shortage would
extend into 2024 or beyond.
(upbeat music)